[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 16 novembre voici le programme
de ce soir elle a 77 ans l'autoroute A13
qui relie Paris à la Normandie fait peau
neuve L c'est en 2016 les travaux
d'élargissement à hauteur de Mantel
jolie se sont achevés en septembre
dernier les quelques 120000
automobilistes quotidiens ont dorénavant
cette voie de circulation d'autres
travaux sont en cours nous avons pu
entrer dans les coulisses du chantier
leurs spectacles font fureur dans le
monde entier le Cirque du soleil revient
en France et ils ont choisi Chatou pour
s'installer jusqu'au 14 janvier ils ont
accepté de nous ouvrir leurs portes pour
filmer les coulisse de leur tout nouveau
spectacle curios le cabinet des
curiosités le jeudi comme d'habitude
nous vous donnerons nos idées de sortie
dans les Yvelines au programme de ce
soir les auditions pour la 9e édition du
trempelin des voix alors si vous vous
sentez l'âme d'un chanteur de talent
rendez-vous à maniléamo ou à
Saint-Germain en lait nous vous
parlerons également du salon vin et
saveur de poissie enfin nos invités du
78 en 2è partie d'émission des trains et
des bateaux miniatures envahissent la
ferme du Mané de montinil Bretonneux ce
weekend on en parle avec nos deux
invités Erwan losac et Gérard menu tous
les deux président d'une association de
modélisme à Montini le Bretonneux ils
seront avec nous tout à l'heure en
deuxème partie d'émission avec moi pour
l'instant en plateau une journaliste de
la rédaction de tv78 Gabrielle Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir ma alors comme
d'habitude le jeudi vous allez nous
présenter vos idées de sortie dans les
ielines pour ce weekend mais avant vous
allez nous faire un point sur les inform
formation du jour à retenir dans les
Evelin vous allez nous parler de quoi ce
soir et bien on parlera notamment
Mathilde de la rencontre hier soir entre
le maire de La Verrière Nicolas
d'Inville avec le ministre Gérald
d'armanin on parlera aussi d'une
initiative solidaire qui devrait faire
plaisir au gourmand je vous en parlerai
dans quelques instants et ce sera dans
quelques instants vous l'avez dit mais
avant on va prendre la direction de la
13 est-ce que c'est une autoroute que
vous empreuntez souvent gabrieloui oui
et je pense les iinois en prendent
beaucoup et bien vous avez peut-être
constaté qu'elle était en travaux depuis
7 ans niveau de Mantel jolie nouveau
viaduc chaussée mise à neuf notre
journaliste Clara de fruto s'appuie
suivre les travaux de rénovation de
l'autoroute regardez un nouveau visage
du viaduc de Guerville vieux de 50 ans
depuis 2016 l'autoroute à 1 fait P neuve
un chantier titanesque qui a duré 7 ans
cette année durant lesqueles les deux
viaducs d'origine ont été entièrement
rénovés mais pas que par exemple on a
rajouté des canivaux d'assaignissement
qui n'existait pas pour récupérer et
traiter l'eau qui tombe sur les viaducs
on a entièrement renouvelé la chaussée
c'estàd qu'on a enlevé on a remis de
l'étanchéité remis une nouvelle chaussée
et puis on a enfin renforcé l'ouvrage
avec de la fibre de carbone pour lui
permettre de repartir pour les 50 années
à venir mais pour y arriver arcadis
maître d'œuve du chantier et le
concessionnaire SAPN filiale du groupe
SANEF ont dû construire un troème viaduc
entre 2016 et 2019 avant de s'attaquer à
la rénovation des de vieducs existants
c'était de construire un troisième
ouvrage sur le Casel nous sommes en ce
moment euh pour permettre en fait de
pouvoir fermer un des deux viaduc a de
réaliser les travaux sans trop gêner les
clients rouvert depuis le 13 septembre
2023 les 120000 conducteurs quotidiens
peuvent maintenant bénéficier de SEP
voies de circulation au lieu de 6 d'une
séparation des voies de circulation
entre les véhicules légers et les poil
lourd depuis Paris et d'une bande
d'arrêt d'urgence pour chaque viaduc
mais pour entièrement mettre à œuf
l'autoroute à tra
le groupe SANEF ne s'arrête pas là 11 km
de chaussée entre le viaduc de guville
et leschangeurs de bonière vont être
rénov le but de ces travaux
c'est de redonner pour au moins 20 ou 30
ans des caractéristiques structurelles
d'une chaussée neuve et au passage on
refait aussi la couche de surface dont
la durée de vie sera un petit peu moins
longue mais qui donc retrouvera elle
aussi des caractéris toute neuve de
confort et d'adhérence pour le confort
et la sécurité des clients de
l'autoroute pour ces travaux le groupe
SANEF a investi près de 12 millions
d'euros et mobilisé 70 à 100 personnes
par face de chantier le tout réalisé de
nuit pour gêner le moins possible les
automobilistes mais l'autre défi de ces
travaux c'est de limiter le plus
possible son impact environnemental ce
qui veut dire utiliser le moins possible
de bitume et de béton bitumineux pour ça
on opte pour une solution de
renforcement innovante avec un système
de géogrille qui permet de ne faire
qu'une seule couche de renforcement
structurel un deuxième levier pour
limiter l'impact Environnmental de ce
chantier c'est d'optimiser le recyclage
et on arrive à recycler sur la plupart
de ce chantier 40 % de l'ancienne
chaussée qui est rabotée et donc
réutilisée à 40 % dans la nouvelle
chaussée qui est mise en œuvre juste
après un système innovant qui réduit
aussi la durée du chantier donc on
arrive à faire entre 800 m et 1 km
chaque semaine en travaillant uniquement
la
nuit avec une fermeture ou des
basculements d'autoroute entre 22h et 5h
ces travaux qui font partie de la
deuxème phase de rénovation des
chaussées de la 13 devrai se finir fin
novembre 2023 prochaine étape de
rénovation la mise en place du flux
libre des barrières de péage en
2024 allez c'est l'heure à présent de
faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les ivelines
[Musique]
et on commence ces informations Gabriel
par une rencontre un élu 5quantinois été
reçu hier soir place Bovo au ministère
de l'Intérieur et des autres maires oui
tout à fait Mathilde le maire de
laavrière Nicolas d'unville était convié
par le ministre Gérald daranin 60
parlementaires et 150 maires avaient
également répondu présent à l'invitation
objectif évoquer le sujet du pouvoir des
maires contre l'insécurité et les
incibilités sur XX Twitter l'élu
yvelinois demande une extension des
pouvoirs de la police municipale suite à
un sentiment d'impuissance des communes
on prend la direction de morpa à présent
où un nouveau système d'imagerie
médicale a été installé oui un un
appareil DIRM a été inauguré hier soir
au centre médical des pyramides cette
technique de rendu multidimensionnelle
par champ magnétique et notamment
utilisé en cancérologie ou encore en
gynécologie attendu depuis plus de 10
ans le centre a obtenu l'autorisation d'
d'installation auprès de l'agence
régionale de santé il y a un an cet été
la machine est entrée en fonctionnement
avec moins de 40 IRM sur tout le
département cette arrivée répondait à
une demande de la population lesction
les réactions au micro de Julien Leroi
il faut effectivement montrer PES
blanche montrer qu'on est capable
d'instruire et de un tel dossier qu'on
est capable d'installer une machine mais
aussi il faut montrer qu'on apporte un
vrai plus aux patients hein il faut
montrer com qu'on s'intègre dans tout le
réseau de soins il y avait un vrai
projet de santé en particulier basé sur
l'imagerie de la femme puisquon a un
spécialiste le docteur FIDA qui fait
beaucoup d'imagerie de la femme et qui
est réputé et donc on a des patientes
sur toute l'île de France qui viennent
ici pour passer le leurs IRM pelvien je
crois que c'était attendu par nos par
nos habitants et aussi par les
cinquantinois de manière générale
compenu aussi vous le savez de la
pénurie de médecin sur le territoire
donc on sait que maintenant voilà on a
une IRM qui vient en plus du scanner qui
était arrivé il y a il y a quelques
quelques
années un élément d'attractivité
supplémentaire pour le territoire de
morpa et pour son bassin de vie on
poursuit ses informations Gabriel avec
un tableau volé de Joséphine de
beauarnet il a été restitué hier à son
propriétaire oui ce portrait peint en
1804 de l'impératrice avait été dérobé
en février 2022 lors de ses vacances le
couple propriétaire de l'œeuvre se fait
cambrioler dans sa maison des Yvelines
ce tableau est retrouvé dans une salle
des ventes aux enchères à Paris en
novembre 2022 le prix de vente surestimé
faitticket le commissaire priseur et les
explications du vendeur ne sont pas
claires après une enquête quatre
personnes sont interpellées ce mercredi
le portrait a été remis à son
propriétaire par le groupement de
gendarmerie des yvelin à Versailles un
soulagement pour lui dont sa famille est
détentrice de l'œuvre Mathilde depuis
son origine on parle maintenant
d'entrepreneuriat cet après-midi avait
lieu une rencontre entre entrepreneur à
l'incubateur Sky cube de 5qutin en
Yveline oui les rencontres 2023 c'était
le nom de cet événement adressé au por
teur de projet il était organisé pour la
9e année consécutive par l'association
créative cybersécurité intelligence
artificielle ou qualité de vie au
travail experts et chefs d'entreprise
animé des conférences pour partager leur
parcours objectif accompagner une
cquantaine d'entrepreneurs dans leur
démarche de création d'entreprise on
écoute les réactions au micro de Clara
de Frutos une conférence pte autour de
des innovations technologiques avec les
cyber justement les cyber attaques et
intelligence
artificielle une autre conférence porte
sur les la RSE et la QVT dans les
entreprises et une autre conférence qui
porte sur la reconversion
professionnelle avec d'anciens sportifs
de haut niveau reconvertis dans
l'entrepreneuriat une initiative
solidaire maintenant ce samedi aura lieu
la 3e édition de l'éclair day oui un
petit plaisir pour lutter contre la
maladie boulanger pâtissier et clients
sont invités à participer à une journée
solidaire ce 18 novembre le principe
Mathilde le client achète sa pâtisserie
en payant un petit supplément tandis que
le vendeur offre les ingrédients
l'ensemble du prix de l'éclair est
reversé à l'association imagine for
Margot des fonds utilisés pour lutter
contre le cancer de l'enfant cette
maladie elle touche aujourd'hui chaque
année 2500 enfants en France l'année
dernière 15000 éclairs avaient été
vendus et 40000 € avaient été collectés
l'ensemble des points de vente
participants est à retrouver sur le site
imagine for
margotorg pardon icheas de c'est une
bonne initiative ça merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news hier c'était la journée mondiale
des écrivains persécutés c'est pourquoi
la médiathèque de la verrière organisit
une table ronde avec trois auteurs en
exil somala ramich masbas et Philomé
Robert ont choisi de quitter leur pays
pour revendiquer leurs écrits et rester
en liberté ce soir nous vous proposons
d'écouter le témoignage de Philomé
Robert journaliste essayiste et
romancier franco-haïtien il répond aux
questions d'Aurélie
[Musique]
lafel mon premier roman s'appelle V âge
éphémère c'est l'histoire d'un camarade
qui n'a absolument rien à voir avec moi
auquel on vole quelque chose et qui
décide de trouver ce qu'on lui a volé et
ce périple ce vagabondage va l'emmener
un peu partout le livre qui est publié
chez Karem édition circule assez bien et
l'histoire semble assez toucher sa
lecteur et sa lectrice et j'en suis
content et je voudrais que le livre
aille encore plus loin en ce moment je
suis en train de travailler sur mon
second c'était chaotique parce que je
suis arrivé ici un matin d'hiver je ne
connaissais absolument personne je
parlais le français mais c'était le
français haïtien c'était pas le français
français et puis j'étais avec ma femme
enceinte de 6 mois et il a fallu
absolument surinventer une vie dans un
pays qui n'est pas le qui était pas le
nôtre j'ai mis longtemps avant de
finalement réaliser que on pouvait
sortir de sa condition question de déjà
demandeur d'asile ensuite de réfugiés
ensuite attraperé quelques bout de
citoyenneté ici ou là mais c'était pas
[Musique]
facile le pouvoir de jeanbert Aristide
avait décrété la mort de la presse
indépendante donc tout journaliste qui
ne prêchait pas la bonne nouvelle de
l'Évangile selon ce pouvoirl était
considéré comme un journaliste
d'opposition absolument à tort moi
aujourd'hui 20 ans plus tard je ne me
considère toujours pas comme ayant été
un journaliste d'opposition même ayant
des affinités avec cette opposition sauf
que quand on a un pouvoir qui organise
des élections qu' organise et qu'il
gagne à 100 % 27 sénateurs 27 sénateurs
du parti 82 députés 82 députés du parti
on n'a pas besoin d'être d'opposition
pour relever que ce sont les élections
truqué et à partir du moment où on a
commencé à le dire le pouvoir a pris la
mouche et ça s fini finalement par des
des agressions des meurtres et cetera
moi j'ai eu la chance d'en RCH mais
d'autres camarades euh ne s'en sont pas
sortis je pense par exemple à un ami
comme BR Lindor qui a été assassiné
lyché le 3 décembre 2001 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il n'a pas obtenu justice sa
famille non plus donc en résumé ce
pouvoir là avait décrété la mort de la
presse indépendante parce que cette
presse là faisait son
travail allez comme chaque jeudi c'est
l'heure à présent de passer à notre page
loisirs
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec le
grand retour du Cirque du Soleil en
France après 5 ans d'absence la
compagnie pose ses bagages sur l'île des
Impressionnistes à Chatou ils ont
accepté de nous ouvrir les portes de
leur chapitaux légendaire Gabriel
Gontier a pu suivre les dernières
répétitions de leur nouveau spectacle
curios le cabinet des
curiosités
[Musique]
l'excitation et l'effervessence des
grands jours après 5 ans d'absence le
Cirque du Soleil fait son grand retour
devant le public français avec l'une de
ses productions phare curios à
l'approche de la première l'heure est
aux dernières répétitions en ce moment
les acrobates véfi que que tout est bien
que la tension du filet est bien donc il
vérifie aussi la que les plateformes
soient bien à niveau puis tout ça pour
que les artistes soient confortables et
puissent présenter les acrobaties de
haut niveau pour atteindre l'excellence
des années de préparation on été
nécessaire pour créer ce spectacle un
travail qui depuis la création de la
compagnie québécoise en
1984 ne cesse de
fasciner
avec près de 3000 collaborateurs la
magie s'opère aussi en coulisse où tout
doit être parfait bonjour je suis Becky
Williams bienvenue dans les backstage
ici nous avons certains accessoires donc
nous avons
464 accessoires ici vous voyez beaucoup
de choses inspirées de la révolution
industrielle le train à vapeur et le
gramophone un de mes accessoir préféré
que nous avons sur le spectacle on vient
de recevoir la touche finale c'est la
main méc on l'utilise pendant le numéro
de
[Musique]
contorion
bienvenue dans la tente des artistes ici
les artistes viennent s'entraîner se
reposer et même se préparer ils
disposent également de leur propre
dressing bonjour je suis Mar je suis la
chef costumière bienvenue dans l'atelier
des costumes suivez-moi on a beaucoup de
travail en vue de cette grande
première alors vous pouvez voir nous
avons beaucoup de perruesou oup de
costumes beaucoup de gens travaill
dessus c'est près de 8000 costumes et
accessoires qui sont entreposés ici
chaque pièce est unique et repousse les
limites de
l'imagination on voyage avec beaucoup de
maquillage avec tout ce dont nous avons
besoin pour réparer les costumes donc
nous avons beaucoup de projets
d'envergure et nous avons beaucoup de
travail pour être prêt pour la
première une machine à rêve qui réunit
une cinquantaine d'artistes de 20
nationalités différentes oui au sein de
curios nous avons beaucoup beaucoup de
nationalité c'est agréable d'être avec
eux et de voir comment ils travaillent
voir leur culture comment ils font ce
qu'ils font c'est juste une belle façon
de vivre un mode de vie synonyme de
fierté pour les membres de la compagnie
il y a tous les amis toute la famill qui
vont venir bien sûr ils sont déjà venus
avant mais il y en a d'autres qui vont
pouvoir avir la chance de pouvoir venir
vu qu'on est plus proche et ça met une
petite pression bien sûr on est en
France donc on a envie de bien faire on
a envie de bien présenter le show et et
super content ouais d'être d'être ici
quoi depuis 39 ans la compagnie a
conquis près de 375 millions de
spectateurs à Chatou 2500 personnes sont
attendu dès la première le Cirque du
Soleil enchantera l'île des
Impressionnistes jusqu'au 14 janvier
2023 on poursuit cette page loisir avec
vos idée de sortie Gabriel qu'est-ce que
vous nous avez concocté ce soir et bien
Mathilde on commence avec un rendez-vous
musical le concours de chant yvelinois
le tremplin des voix revient pour une 9e
édition proposée par l'association la
voix en scène vous pouvez venir assister
aux auditions de ses futurs talents
après la présélection des candidats ce
weekend ont lieu les auditions devant le
jury et le show est ouvert au public
depuis plusieurs années le concours du
tremplin des voies apporte un
accompagnement personnalisé aux artistes
tout en leur donnant l'opportunité de
faire de la scène pour les découvrir des
places sont encore disponibles sur le
site du trempelin des vois et ce weekend
c'est aussi le retour des Ludy days oui
des samedis et jusqu'au 25 novembre les
passionnés de jeux ont rendez-vous dans
le réseau des médias de Saint-Quentin en
evelim au programme une semaine
consacrée aux jeux de société mais aussi
jeux de plateau escape game ou encore
jeux vidéo des animations seront
également organisées notamment par des
associations de jeux yvelinois
l'événement est gratuit et ouvert à tous
on va prendre un peu de hauteur à
présent avec un spectacle
d'aéromodélisme
oui alors l'association modélisme et
loisirs technique vous propose un
spectacle aérien d'intérieur au total
une trentaine de pilotes feront voler
des reproduction d'une cinquantaine
d'avions parfois avoisinant jusqu'à 2 m
vous retrouverez des avions de
différentes époques mais aussi une
escadriie à l' figie des Jeux Olympiques
pour assister au spectacle rendez-vous
dimanche après-midi au gymnase du levent
de Fontenel le fleuri et on parlera
modélisme avec nos invités également et
oui d'ailleurs ils sont en plateau avec
nous on continue vos idées de sortie
Gabriel avec un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer à poissie pour les gourmands oui
les producteurs du salon vin et saveur
vous donnent rendez-vous ce weekend pour
la 12e édition du salon durant 2 jours
vous allez pouvoir aller à la rencontre
des producteurs locaux de toute la
France mais aussi bien sûr des Yveline
venus présenter leur production parmi
eux charcutiers traiteurs brasseurs ou
encore vigneron de quoi vous donner
peut-être quelques idées de produits à
mettre sur votre table à Noël Mathilde
vous allez faire un tour Gabriel je je
pense que ça peut être une bonne idée je
pense aussi en tout cas noël approche à
grand pas vous l'avez dit alors pourquoi
pas commencer à rêver dès maintenant
avec un spectacle façon Broadway oui
dans cette représentation les artistes
reviennent sur les plus belles pages de
la comédie musicale américaine parmi
elles certaines rendues célèbr comme
Moon River dans breakfast at Tiffany
avec Audrey hebburn qui a valu un Oscar
au compositeur celui de la meilleure
musique de film sur scène pour
interpréter ses œuvres un trio
d'artistes qui reexplore cet univers né
dans les années folles le concert il a
lieu dimanche Mathilde au château de Buc
et on termine avec du sport et un match
important oui ce sera le match à ne pas
louper ce weekend dans les evelines en
Coupe de France où qui évolue en
Régionale 1 va affronter anger un club
de Ligue 2 ça se passe ce samedi à 14h
ce 7e tour de la Coupe de France devrait
attirer plus de 200 personnes 2000
personnes pardon sur place des places
seront en vente le jour du match à la
billetterie oui est le dernier
représentant des evines dans cette
compétition et on leur souhaite bonne
chance bien sûr même si le match
s'annonce très compliqué face à anger
merci beaucoup Gabriel pour pour toutes
ces idées de sortie c'est bientôt
l'heure de passer aux invités du 78 mais
avant je vous propose de jeter un coup
d'œil à la météo de
demain demain matin nous devrions rester
au sec normalement du côté de Mantel
jolie et de versaill le ciel sera dégagé
mais vert oudans et rembouillé le ciel
sera bien nuageux au niveau des
températures il fera 6°gr à rouiller et
oudans 7 à versaill et 8 à Mantel jolie
demain après-midi les nuages auront
gagné une grande partie des zvelines
seul le secteur de Versailles devrait
avoir quelques éclaircis côté
température compteé 11 à 12° en moyenne
dans le département et pour les
prévisions météo de ce weekend ce sera
gris samedi il devrait pleuvoir toute la
journée selon Météo France niveau
température il fera environ 9°gr le
matin et 12°g l'après-midi dimanche pas
de pluie mais un ciel très nuageux côté
température il fera en moyenne 12°gr le
matin et 13° l'après-midi c'est l'heure
à présent de passer aux invités du
[Musique]
78 et ce soir nous allons parler de
trains et de bateaux miniature avec nos
invités Erwan losac bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le président de
l'association Les Amis des Flo à vos
côtés Gérard menu bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le président de l'association les
passionnés du train comme chaque année
vous allez donner une exposition avec
des centaines de trains de bateaux ou
encore d'avion miniature vous vous nous
en avez apporté quelquesuns est-ce que
vous pouvez nous les
présenter comme vous voulez alors cela
ça c'est une voiture de américaine qui a
une échelle très importante du LGB ce
qu'on appppelle du LGB et qui don nous
allons avoir un un réseau qui va te
faire ce genre de maquette donc c'est
électrique ce sera électrique ce sera
sur cette échelle sera sur batterie mais
nous avons aussi un autre grand réseau
qui va faire presque plus de 50 m² de de
50 m de long pardon qui où il y aura des
trains beaucoup plus petit à l'échelle
ce qu'on appelle de échelle de ha le
187e oui parce que l'échelle est très
importante Dansou voilà il y a plusieurs
échelles et donc vouswan vous avez
apporté un un bateau est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous le présenter également
ouais tout à fait c'est un bateau que
j'ai fait avec mon fils quand il avait 4
4 5 ans et c'est le genre de petit
bateau qu'on va prêter aux enfants pour
faire de l'écollage comme on appelle
donc ils auront une radio commmande
comme ça ils pourront accélérer avec la
gâchette tourner le gouvernail avec ce
genre de télécommande et sur un bassin
de 50 m² aussi dédié pas que à
l'écollage il y aura aussi des
démonstrations par les exposants des des
six clubs de bateau représentés sur
place
ce sera quels sont ces clubs justement
de bateau alors il y a des clubs de
Massie il y a le club de mant la jolie
et par l'encour saint-ris les Chevreuse
poissie euh nous nous-même de montinivre
tenux donc ça vient de toutes les
ivelines c'est ça et oui et donc il y
aura différents types de de bateau des
bateaux à voile on a'ura pas de bateau à
voile à proprement parler puisqu'on a
pas de ventilateur sur le bassin etord
mais il y aura des bateaux à moteurs de
différents types ouais que ce soit pêche
ou ou des Cros chalutiers des des
bateaux de commerce et vous avez
beaucoup d'exposants cette année à la
ferme du Mané là on en est si on compte
les organisateurs on est 150 exposants
pour une trentaine de de stand d'accord
avec des voitures radio commmandées le
club de Montine Bretonneux vient aussi
avec les voitures radio commmandées qui
prêteront aux enfants pour rouler sur
sur un circuit en moquette sur pareil 80
m² il y a le club de morpa qui vient
avec un un circuit 24 c'estàd du slot
racing c'est sont des petites voitures
guidées par un rail avec le même genre
de pistolet mais avec un fil donc c'est
ça reste une une exposition familiale
euh où les enfants peuvent toucher les
parents aussi évidemment mais ils sont
pas obligés de garder les mains dans les
poches et toucher avec les yeux pour une
fois ils pourront manipuler les les
trains les bateaux les petit voit
petites voitures c'est un peu un rêve
d'enfant en fait le le modélisme non s
oui on peut dire ça c'est devenu de plus
en plus technique aussi maintenant oui
c'est technique ça demande du temps
j'imagine pour créer une maquette ça
demande un certain temps ouais ouais
faut bien compter une maquette comme
vous avez présenté une maquette qui fait
80 cm de long faut compter à peu près un
à 2 mois de réalisation ah oui donc de
la patience et de la précision paence de
la précision et de l'envie aussi bien
sûr faut être motivé
ouais dans vos associations mutuellement
on imagine que c'est essentiellement des
passionnés qui consacre tout leur temps
à ça on consacre beaucoup de temps oui
pas tout le temps mais beaucoup de temps
à ça ouais ouai tout à fait et alors
apparemment il y aura aussi une maquette
du Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin
en Yveline tout à fait tout à fait c'est
vous qui l'avez réalisé c'est nous qui
l'avons fait réaliser oui oui c'est une
maquette qui est au au au 2 cè bien sûr
parce que B c'est à peu près grande
comme ça en gros et elle sera exposée
éctement mais alors on l'a fait ouverte
on on a coupé les les pans un un certain
Pan et puis on n pas mis de de toit pour
que les spectateurs puissent voir
l'intérieur du Vélodrome et on a une à
peu près 2500 petits personnages qui ont
été collé dans les gradins au-delà du
loisir c'est aussi une façon de rendre
hommage à notre patrimoine oui aussi
tout à fait puisqu'on on ni aussi bien
aussi bien au Vélodrome qu'au train on a
aussi beaucoup de de maquettes qui
représenteront des trains qui rouleront
qui sont des anciens des représentations
d'anciens comme leorient Express ou des
choses comm ou le le Capitol ou des
choses comme ça demande un peu de
recherche aussi du coup oui ça demande
aussi quelques recherches oui parce que
les les les trains on a l'habitude de
mettre des petits personnage à
l'intérieur de mettre de l'éclairage et
de peindre bien sûr les les fauteuils
dans le qu'on peut trouver dans la
couleur d'origine est-ce que ça coûte
cher de de produire soi-même sa propre
maquette B ça dépend ça dépend de la
compteur de la maquette faut compter au
point de vue comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure une maquette de 80 cm faut
compter à peu près une une cinquantaine
de morceaux de bois plus après de pour
vous faire le sature après ben c'est du
suivant la les personnages alors de la
peinture du plâtre ou du polystyrène et
tout a avec un peu de décor donc faut
compter à peu près euh
je disais entre 200 et 300 et 500 €
suivant la la complexité ouais quand
même est-ce que vous avez des conseils
pour nos téléspectateurs alors celle-ci
par par contre c'est que du bois de
récupération co il y a 50 € 60 €
d'électronique dedans alors est-ce que
vous avez des conseils pour nos
téléspectateurs qui aimeraient se lancer
dans dans le modélisme mais qui savent
pas trop par où commencer bah qui
viennent de voir déjà on leur donnera
des conseils c'est ça de pas se lancer
tout seul ou pas parce que après c'est
une perte de temps finalement on gagne
beaucoup de temps à être conseillé par
d'autres d'autres personnes
expérimenté et puis bien sûr il y a
quelques quelques revues qui peuvent les
aider beaucoup dans qui ont beaucoup de
de de parution qui peuvent aidé dans le
modélisme pour les trains mais al pour
le bateau il en reste plus qu'une
malheureusement en France en presse
papier d'accord en presse vraiment
écrite il y a plus qu'une seule une
seule édition qui fait ça et alors pour
revenir à l'exposition à la ferme du
Mané est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
surprises cette année ou pas B il y aura
le vélodrome bien sûr mais il a déjà été
présenté oui il y aura quelques
surprises aussi oui il y aura quelques
nouveautés par rapport à l'édition qu'on
a fait en 2019 comme quoi vous voulez
les dévoiler ou vous voulez garder sa
non nous on aura des démonstrations de
camion radio commmandé qu'on avait pas
eu en
2019s bien Gabriel une dernière question
oui petite question comme ça dans vos
associations quels sont les les les
personnes qui adhèrent à l'association
vous avez des enfants également qui
viennent construire avec vous c'est ces
modèles ou c'est plutôt des des adultes
ouais ce sont plutôt des adultes pour
pour notre part puisqueon on on limite
l'accès à 16 ans pour éviter de faire
garderie on veut bien des des enfants
plus jeunes mais les parents restent
avec eux pour travailler avec eux vous
l'avez dit vous vous l'avez fait ce
bateau avec votre F voilà c'est ça voilà
nous aussi nous avons la même
philosophie et bien merci beaucoup Erwan
losac et Gérard menu d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en plateau alors si
vous êtes intéressé la troisème
exposition du modélisme c'est ce weekend
à la ferme du Mané de Montini le
Bretonneux de 10h à 19h pour le samedi
et de 10h à 18h pour le dimanche
l'entrée est à 3 € c'est gratuit pour
les moins de 12 ans et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur
tv78 prenez soin vous prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous